défaveur avec roger gicquel chine procès
ouvert une dizaine d'accusés dont la
bande des quatre ont commencé à répondre
aujourd'hui de leur crime contre
révolutionnaire georges marchais cent
trente et une proposition
le candidat communiste aux
présidentielles présente son nouveau
plan de lutte otage un pas vers la
libération
c'est la question que l'on peut se poser
après l'acceptation par les états unis
du principe des quatre conditions
iraniennes
bonsoir c'est encore la chine qui nous
étonne le plus aujourd'hui avec cette
extraordinaire procès de la bande des
quatre et des généraux
contre-révolutionnaires un double procès
qui se fera seulement en partie au grand
jour mais de quelle manière les caméras
de télévision sont là et bien là pour le
dernier acte d'un spectacle politico
judiciaire destinée à conjurer les
démons en enterrant tout un passé y
compris sans doute tout un chapitre de
l'héritage de out c'est tout ce que l'on
juge sont pratiquement les derniers
survivants de la révolution culturelle
aujourd'hui la veuve de mao et sa bande
des quatre mais également cinq généraux
complice du maréchal lindau mort dans un
accident d'avion en 71 et plus tard on
annonce que plusieurs dizaines de
dirigeants gauchistes seront également
jugés alors je vous laisse regarder les
images de ce procès géant dans tous les
sens du mot
avec jacqueline du bois c'est le dernier
acte du drame que la chine vit depuis la
mort de son grand timonier
le président de la cour populaire site
web chinois déclare l'audience avec le
premier accusé wang wang 44 ans le plus
jeune membre de la bande des quatre
ancien ouvrier devenu président du parti
communiste chinois tête rasée comme tous
les criminels en chine
le boom est non
un manuel c'est son tour 54 ans
journaliste c'est lui qui a donné le
coup d'envoi la révolution culturelle en
1966 et puis c'est le tour des jeunes
des généraux accusés d'avoir voulu
assassiner mao sous les ordres de link
yao ils ont l'air défait
et puis jane fonda l'ancien secrétaire
de mao et fusées par l'épreuve il est
soutenu par deux policiers et voici
zhang chunxian la tête pensante de la
bande des cas la chose que tu m appelles
chan chin
la vedette de cette pièce de théâtre
hors série sur laquelle les yeux du
monde sont rivés actuellement ancienne
actrice elle le sait et elle entre la
tête haute
le regard fier cette femme dont mao
tombant amoureux et qui fige son épouse
pendant 37 ans est aujourd'hui haï par
le peuple chinois
le président l'accusent de la
persécution y compris au moyen de
sévices physiques souvent mortelle
d'innombrables artistes et écrivains
elle a refusé d'être assisté par les
avocats qu'on lui avait proposé
elle préfère se défendre seul elle
refuse de fruges foutant cette femme
comme les autres invités a été résistant
elle a subi deux temps d'asseoir dans ce
cas selon l'instruction a duré quatre
ans parce qu'il fallait non seulement
préparer les incultes et saufs ils le
connaissent leur fille il fallait aussi
préparer l'opinion publique
aucun d'eux ne doit subsister au sujet
de la culture qualité des invités
ils sont accusés de conspiration pour
renverser la dictature du prolétariat de
persécutions contre les dirigeants du
parti et de l'état dans l'intention de
s'emparer du toujours
ils sont accusés d' une dictature
fasciste et complot visant à assassiner
le président marc dutroux
selon le code pénal chinois siffre ils
sont sanctionnés par la peine capitale
bien que le verdict soit inconnu une
chose est sûre les accusés ici présents
ne sont pas acquittés
car leur acquittement instituerait un
démenti de toutes les accusations
formulées contre par le gouvernement de
fixer à sonnac et puis s'il refuse de le
connaître leur swing l'article 35 du
code pénal chinois insipide que la vue
des accusés n'est pas indispensable si
des preuves comme un sens ont su être le
pays par d'autres moyens
voilà suite de ce procès dans les jours
qui viennent car il va durer longtemps
ce procès les etats unis ont accepté le
principe des quatre conditions
iraniennes pour la libération des otages
américains c'est le secrétaire d'état
muschi qui vient de l'annoncer et une
équipe de négociateurs américains
devraient maintenant devrait partir à
alger où se négocieront toutes les
phases concrètes de cette libération
jean loup demigneux peu avant les
élections américaines ronald regan à
propos de la possibilité de faire
libérer les otages avaient dit j'ai mon
idée
après l'élection il disait jimmy carter
est toujours pour deux mois le président
nous lui laissons les mains libres pour
régler cette affaire mais que les
iraniens ne s'y trompe pas il n'aurait
aucun intérêt à essayer de gagner du
temps bien sûr les otages après plus
d'un an de détention ne sont pas encore
libérés mais le dénouement approche
cela ne fait plus guère de doute le
premier ministre iranien ali rajaï ce
matin déclare que pour lui le problème
est réglé mais qu'il ne faudrait pas que
les américains cherchent à mêler aux
discussions sur la libération des otages
des problèmes politiques et cherche à
mener des entretiens de longue durée
quelques heures plus tard le secrétaire
d'état américain déclare à la presse que
son pays acceptent le principe des
quatre conditions iraniennes pour la
libération des 52 otages mais qu'il faut
encore discuter de l'application de ces
principes
alors le problème est il vraiment réglé
presque
mais de part et d'autre les restrictions
existent et la prudence subsistent il
n'empêche on sait aujourd'hui que la
formule de dialogue par algérien
interposés fonctionne on a de plus la
confirmation que désormais ce sont
surtout les iraniens qui considèrent
qu'ils n'ont plus aucun intérêt à ce que
la sphère continue de s'éterniser
les 52 otages ne passeront donc
peut-être pas une seconde fois à noël en
iran peut-être mais attendons plan de
lutte contre la crise pour le changement
cent trente et une proposition de
georges marchais c'est le document de 50
pages qui servira de base à la campagne
électorale du candidat communiste à la
présidence de la république
objectif supprimer le chômage rendre le
travail plus humain la société plus
juste la vie libre et responsable
mais georges marchais averti qu'il a
tiré les leçons de l'expérience du
programme commun
il n'entend pas faire des promesses les
changements at il dit ne viendront pas
sur un plateau d'argent c'est aux
travailleurs de s'emparer de ses
objectifs pour en faire des réalités et
georges marchais conclu je suis persuadé
que mon langage sera entendu et alors
rira bien qui rira le dernier
les détails de ce plan de lutte jacques
hébert eu la période des fêtes
approchant à grands pas et pour prendre
bien entendu une image on avait un peu
l'impression d'assister à une
distribution anticipé de cadeaux ce
matin dans le sous sol de l'immeuble du
parti communiste place du colonel fabien
jugez vous même parmi les 130 et une
proposition du candidat communiste aux
présidentielles on trouve par exemple le
smic tout de suite à 3300 francs la
semaine de 35 heures
la création annuelle de 500 mille
emplois dont 350 milles pour les femmes
ça sent francs d'allocations familiales
par enfant et par semaine et puis la
cinquième semaine de congés payés
l'éventail des salaires limité de 1 à 4
la construction de 500 milles hlm
parents ou encore l'enseignement et les
soins gratuits
voilà pour quelques objectifs les moyens
maintenant georges marchais les définit
par cette phrase une nouvelle croissance
française
laquelle passe par de nouveaux
investissements la bonne organisation
notre industrie l'indépendance
énergétique la réduction de la tva
l'impôt sur le capital l'arrêt de
l'immigration etc etc
le candidat communiste propose aussi une
nouvelle et longue liste de
nationalisation touchant quasiment tous
les secteurs mais voilà si les objectifs
sont chiffrées au centime près il n'en
est pas de même pour les moyens si bien
évidemment le point faible de ce nouveau
programme communiste
le point qui suscitera certainement le
plus de polémiques
toutefois parmi les propositions
chiffrées il ya notamment celles qui
tendent à augmenter fortement l'impôt
sur les hauts revenus
écoutez ce qu'on a dit georges marchais
ce matin par l'ons en anciens francs
s'ils roulaient à partir de 1 million
600 mille anciens francs il y à un impôt
progressif et à partir de 4 millions
d'anciens francs
nous prenons tous
je ne suis pas un démagogue
c'est clair c'est clair voyez bien rira
bien qui rira le dernier
je prends tout mais je vous pose la
question je vous pose la question
peut-on parler de justice peut-on parler
de mener le combat pour la justice et en
même temps refuser de donner aux
salariés qui sont au smic 3300 anciens
francs par mois tandis que d'autres
gagnent effectivement plus de 4000
françois mitterrand lui aussi dénoncé le
chômage à villefranche de rouergue où il
soutenait le candidat socialiste claude
penel pour l'élection législative
partielle de dimanche à son retour à
paris voici moins d'une demi heure
le candidat socialiste à l'elysée a
répondu aux questions de bruno masure
l'entretien a porté notamment sur les
problèmes des forces nucléaires
françaises et sur leur éventuel
déclenchement et cela deux jours après
notre émission sur ce sujet où monsieur
giscard d'estaing décrivait dans quelles
conditions
le chef de l'état devait être
nécessairement sun revenir sur la
dissuasion c'est pratiquement privé
notre armée du moyen de défendre le pays
des socialistes après avoir longtemps
réfléchi ont estimé devoir désormais se
rallier à ce mode de défense de la
patrie
à partir de là se pose beaucoup de
questions bien entendu le président de
la république les imposer mais pas
toutes
par exemple lorsqu'il parle de la bombe
à neutrons
at il expliqué à c'est ce que c'était
c'est une arme dont on ne peut se servir
qu'en sortant de nos frontières
puisqu'il les présupposés qu'un
adversaire éventuel dont les trous dont
les armées viennent vers le territoire
national ils sont pas encore parvenues
puisque s'ils y sont parvenus c'est la
bombe atomique
ce sont les fusils qui partent ou ce
sont les sous marins quitté en acceptant
la bombe à neutrons le président de la
république a accepté de se placer dans
une situation qui verrait la france
s'engager dans une guerre atomique sans
que nécessairement son existence soit
anges aux jouets de la bombe atomique
appuyés comme on dit vulgairement sur le
bouton cela veut dire que l'on s'engage
dans ce conflit terrible qui consiste
tout simplement à mettre en jeu
l'existence des millions de français
quelques bombes adverse
je ne dirais pas leur nationalité
quelques bombes adverse suffirait à
détruire le sol national et ceux qui
vivent à partir de là je pense que la
dissuasion pose deux questions la
première qui vient à l'esprit que tout
le monde
aussitôt elle examine le président de la
république l'a fait c'est que il faut
avoir un président de la république chef
de l'état puisqu'il est tout seul à
pouvoir prendre cette décision en raison
de la rapidité des événements est il
capable d'appuyer sur le bouton de
déclencher la guerre atomique
il faut en tout cas que l'adversaire
éventuel en soit sur ce en quoi ils n'y
croient plus à notre force de dissuasion
il faut poser deuxième question qui n'a
pas été vraiment posée par le président
de la république est ce que le chef de
l'état est capable de ne pas déclencher
la guerre atomique
c'est à dire at il pris assez de
précautions avant pour que cette
situation ne puisse être abordée
je veux dire par là qu'entre en jeu le
problème des alliances des traités
d'amitié les problèmes du désarmement
des problèmes de l' équilibre mondial
c'est tout notre diplomatie diplomatie
qui doit dire une diplomatie sagesse
mais aussi de fermeté qu'il s'oppose à
une diplomatie de faiblesse ou de
compromission qui elle peut provoquer le
déséquilibre mondial et à partir du
déséquilibre mondial
alors la guerre atomique est possible et
on se retrouve devant la deuxième plus
tôt la première hypothèse alors le chef
de l'état est il en mesure morale
psychologique le caractère d'appuyer sur
le bouton qui fait que la france se
trouve emporté dans un conflit terrible
je voudrais insister sur ce point je ne
crois pas qu'il soit possible de
distribuer de diffuser le pouvoir de
décider une guerre atomique
cela peut se faire en l'espace de
quelques minutes
j'allais presque dire quelques secondes
comment consulter d'autres moi j'ai
pensé en d'autres temps tout de même le
chef d'état major général des armées et
que le premier ministre devait être en
mesure de donner l'opinion qu'un seul
homme puisse eu une et du droit à
l'erreur une façon irrévocable ensuite
curial mais la dissuasion
ça doit servir à ne pas s'en servir
c'est parce que l'on peut dissuader ou
convaincre nets versés éventuels que
l'on est capable de mettre en jeu
d'un seul coup toutes les forces dont
nous disposons et surtout celle des cinq
sous marins nucléaires des sous marins
nucléaires qui devrait d'ailleurs être
plus nombreux c'est à partir de là que
s'établit nouvel équilibre psychologique
on ne nous attaquent pas et c'est
surtout sur ceux prenant la une le
président de la république aurait besoin
de nous prouver davantage 6
sans eux
tout à fait autre chose françois
mitterrand très rapidement parce que
nous avons peu de temps mon et sondages
se multiplient et pour le moment ils ne
sont pas exagérément optimistes à votre
égard est ce que vous n'êtes pas
certains jours décourager et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire d'abord le meilleur
sondage c'est les élections vous aurez
dimanche prochain cette élection
partielle 500000 françaises et français
qui voteront attendait le résultat et on
jugera but parler des sondages si
monsieur pompidou avait écouté la loi
les sondages il se serait pas présenté
pour ce monsieur power jet me demande ce
que réfé monsieur reagan il y a un ou
deux ans à la même époque
de la même façon j'ai connu à travers
ces dernières années notamment lorsque
je me suis présenté face au général de
gaulle en 1965 des sondages qui aurait
vérité votre réflexion est ce que
vraiment ça vous inquiète pas et le
général de gaulle lui même s'ils
s'étaient tenues au sondage du mois
d'avril
1958 à un mois avant de revenir au
pouvoir et pour longtemps
je serais pas présenté j'ai pas qu'il ne
dépassait pas 14%
bref si vous voulez arrêtons cette
discussion futile d'autre part les
conditions de votre candidature à la
candidature et le retrait michel rocard
ont un peu surpris les français est ce
que ça ne va pas ajouter un handicap
politique ou psychologique
supplémentaire pour vous et selon vous
est-ce que le les plaisançois cicatriser
au parti et sur quel programme sur
quelle idée sur quel thème exactement va
se faire la campagne socialiste s'est
fait beaucoup de questions à la fois les
plaies alors ce sont des plaies de la
démocratie nous sommes le seul parti à
ouvrir une discussion pour le choix de
notre candidat
les autres il décide tout seul et
s'impose de mamie consulte personne
sinon dans le secret
nous nous agissons différemment à ciel
ouvert n'est ce pas mieux
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a des plaies
se faisait il ya des discussions
et quand la discussion s'achève c'est la
loi de la majorité qui s'impose c'est
encore ça la démocratie
d'autre part
n'est pas de ma faute si ayant déclaré
aux socialistes que je déposerai ma
candidature auprès des socialistes
les autres candidats se sont de même
retiré je ne leur ai pas demandé
alors laissez moi vous dire que les
socialistes ils ont très envie de se
mobiliser
ils ont d'abord envie de battre le
pouvoir actuel de changer la politique
c'est autour de ce thème que la
mobilisation se fera pas ce qu'est ce
que je peux vous dire alors être une
bataille perdue pour une association de
consommateurs l'ufc et sa revue que
choisir
après avoir gagné sur le veau aux
hormones elle subit une dure défaite
contre le pneumatique plus précisément
contre la société kléber colombes et les
pneus v10 et v12 qu'elle avait désigné
comme dangereux le tribunal a condamné
l' ufc a versé 250 mille francs de
dommages et intérêts la société de
pneumatiques
christian barquisseau kléber colombes
gagne donc son procès contre l'union
fédérale des consommateurs après une
campagne contre le pneu v12 qui a
durement secoué la société des
pneumatiques pendant neuf mois kléber
colombes a subi un lourd préjudice qui
l'a amené à faire des campagnes
publicitaires massives pour compenser
celle de l'union des consommateurs par
l'intermédiaire de son journal que
choisit l'organisation avait affirmé que
les pneus v10 et v12 était dangereux est
avait réclamé le retrait du marché
mais après des analyses effectuées par
les services techniques officiels
le ministre de l'économie monsieur
monory concluait que rien ne permettait
d'établir l'existence d'un défaut
systématique dans la fabrication et la
conception de ses pneumatiques pour le
président de kléber le jugement du
tribunal est nette
l'union des consommateurs n'a pas
satisfait à son obligation de se livrer
à des études objective et sérieuse et a
donc dépasser très largement ses
obligations de prudence
je n'ai pas là en cause du tout le
consumérisme en général les
organisations de consommateurs en
général je dis qu'il y à certains
comportements qui peuvent être induits
par je ne sais pas moi le fait que le
boycott est un produit qui se vend bien
quand on est une entreprise
d'information puisque sur une
organisation consommateur peut être
aussi une entreprise d'information on
peut être tenté de vendre du boycott
parce que c'est à la mode
l'union fédérale des consommateurs a
décidé de faire appel de ce jugement
considérant qu'elle a été condamnée sans
avoir plaidé ni fourni tous les
documents justifiant la demande de
retrait du marché de ses pneumatiques
de son côté la firme kléber colombes a
décidé après cette expérience de se
lancer à son tour dans la création d'une
association de consommateurs en
précisant de consommateurs adultes en
pologne
les récentes victoires des syndicats
libres ne doivent pas faire oublier qu
une lutte sourde continue en permanence
a opposé dans la classe politique ceux
qui souhaitent réellement une
émancipation à la polonaise et ceux qui
restent partisans de plus de fermeté
aujourd'hui encore la presse officielle
insiste sur le rôle prééminent du parti
d'autre part le nouveau syndicat des
chantiers navals de guide de dinia
s'indigne de la nomination à la tête du
comité du parti de varsovie d'un
dirigeant qu'elle accuse d'avoir jadis
réprimer les grèves des grèves de
décembre 70 enfin la chaîne de
télévision cbs cite un rapport des
services de renseignement américains
selon lequel l'union soviétique aurait
perdu toute confiance dans l'équipe
dirigeante actuelle en pologne et serait
prête à intervenir militairement
aujourd'hui à l'elysée le président de
la république a reçu une lettre de
créance de quatre nouveaux ambassadeurs
et notamment du nouvel ambassadeur de
pologne
monsieur poulaga et l'allocution de
monsieur giscard d'estaing au nouvel
ambassadeur polonais a nettement dépassé
le cadre protocolaire habituel gérard
saint paul oui c'est vrai le président
de la république a eu des paroles très
net et même chaleureuse à l'égard de
monsieur kwaga le nouvel ambassadeur de
pologne en france par exemple le
président giscard d'estaing dit ceci
plus d'un combat commun pour leur
liberté et leur dignité à rassembler la
france et la pologne dans la période
récente
les deux pays ont développé une
coopération à bien des égards modèle
ceci at il poursuivi constitue un acquis
auquel la france est profondément
attaché et voici peut-être le passage le
plus important c'est dire a affirmé le
président giscard d'estaing l'attention
que nous portons aux efforts en cours
pour répondre aux aspirations profondes
de votre peuple le peuple polonais la
pologne doit trouver en elle-même est en
elle seule la réponse à ces problèmes
toute son histoire manifeste de la force
irréductibles de sa personnalité et
l'attachement de son peuple à conserver
la maîtrise de son destin
fin de citation manifestement pour les
polonais qui savent lire entre les
lignes
le message est clair il fait appel à une
position traditionnelle de la diplomatie
française c'est à dire pas d'ingérence
dans les affaires des autres
il rappelle également spesa que les
relations entre paris et varsovie font
partie de la détente alors application
pratique de ces principes
la france fera ce qu'il faut et
puisqu'elle est sensible aux difficultés
économiques de la pologne
elle accordera aux polonais de nouvelles
facilités financières
ce ne sont pas des promesses à long
terme cela se passera demain puisque le
vice-président du gouvernement polonais
monsieur jaxaay ce qui est attendu à
paris où il rencontrera jean
françois-poncet rené monory et le
président giscard d'estaing quand il est
vrai que pour la pologne
le risque le plus grave au fond ce
serait l'indifférence et l' isolement
et puis faut faire face à la crise
économique jean-pierre à bout les autres
nouvelles de ce journal oui le président
de la république a reçu en fin d'après
midi le premier ministre pour examiner
avec lui les mesures qui permettront de
maintenir en 1981 le revenu des
agriculteurs
ces dispositions sont rendu public le 5
décembre prochain à l'issue de la
conférence annuelle qui réunit les
représentants des agriculteurs et les
responsables gouvernementaux y avait
également un conseil restreint cet après
midi à l'elysée sous la présidence de
monsieur giscard d'estaing il s'agissait
d'examiner un plan de formation
professionnelle des jeunes pour les cinq
prochaines années ce plan a pour but
d'assurer à tous les jeunes une
formation professionnelle qu'ils devront
avoir reçu au moment de leur entrée dans
la vie active à faire peyrefitte le
monde
jacques fauvet directeur du journal le
monde et philippe boucher éditorialistes
ont été inculpées cet après midi par le
doyen des juges d'instruction du
tribunal de paris
d'infraction à l'article 226 du code
pénal qui réprime les atteintes à
l'autorité et à la dépendance de la
justice après son inculpation
monsieur jacques fauvet a déclaré nous
n'avons rien à retrancher des papiers
incriminés et nous les republier
s'il le fallait ouverture d'une
information contre monsieur frédéric
scène pour reconstitution d'associations
dissoutes
monsieur henry dont en ville procureur
général de la cour de sûreté de l'état a
ouvert une information à l'encontre du
leader de l'ex fans
monsieur frédéric scène avait créé avant
que la fan de soit dissoute
deux autres associations les faisceaux
nationalistes européens et le centre de
culture européenne
la mairie de chamalières a été occupé ce
matin et jusqu'en début d'après-midi par
des syndicalistes cgt de manufrance la
mairie de chamalières près de clermont
ferrand est une mairie célèbre le
président de la république valéry
giscard d'estaing en était le maire
avant son élection en 1974 grosse
agitation en bourse sur le sucre avec
l'offensive italienne pour prendre le
contrôle de la firme française beggas et
le président du groupe monsieur verne a
démenti en disant que la direction était
décidé à préserver une majorité
françaises il faut dire que l'enjeu est
de taille
le groupe bkc est l'un des premiers
producteurs français de sucre à partir
de dimanche après demain la récupération
des huiles usagées sera obligatoire
il s'agit des huiles de moteur qui
jusqu'à présent étaient très souvent
rejetés dans la nature les égouts ou les
décharges crg seront désormais
sanctionnés par des peines de prison ou
des amants ces mesures ont pour but de
préserver l'environnement est également
de faire des économies
ronald reagan à washington à l'heure
actuelle les reagan sont reçus par les
carter qui leur font les honneurs de la
maison blanche leur future résidence
hier monsieur reagan s'était rendu au
congrès où il a rappelé devant les
sénateurs qu'il avait un mandat non pas
tant pour gouverner que pour servir
monsieur reagan s'est également rendu à
la cour suprême à la grande satisfaction
des magistrats et l'a reçu à la surprise
générale le sénateur edward kennedy
promis libyens s'apprêtent à attaquer la
capitale du tchad
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirment les
militaires américains qui précise que
les troupes libyennes se trouvent
seulement à 50 km au nord d'une jam ena
ou des combats se déroulent contre les
forces de monsieur hissène habré qui
contrôle une partie de la capitale
un accident spectaculaire
atteint au centre de belgrade en
yougoslavie un tramway est bondée de
monde se diriger vers la foire de
belgrade il allait trop vite il s'est
renversé dans une courbe
soixante six personnes ont été blessées
dont six grièvement
il y avait un quarter cet après-midi
arras m pour gagner il fallait jouer le
12 le 16 le 18 et le dise un très gros
rapports 240000 695 francs pour 5 francs
dans l'ordre 14100 3 francs toujours
pour 5 francs dans le désordre
selon le pmu il n'ya que 85 personnes
qu'ils ont joué dans l'ordre le temps
maintenant et bien on aurait pu croire
aujourd'hui qu'on avait fait un pas de
géant par de sully vers le ciel et les
températures étaient ceux d'un mois
d'avril et ça va continuer demain il
fera un peu frais le matin ensuite eu
ras du soleil et il fera bon toutefois
attention aux bancs de brouillard de
l'aquitaine au massif central et puis
sur les régions littorales de la manche
le temps va rester nuageux tout de même
avec des petites piques mais toujours du
temps doux
le cinéma d'horreur de cauchemar
d'hallucinations fait de plus en plus
recette partout partout dans le monde et
on a là une preuve supplémentaire à
paris au festival du film fantastique où
on fait la queue pour voir des dizaines
de films inédits qui sont présentés
c'est un peu comme si l'ancien théâtre
du grand guignol prenait en ricanant sa
revanche dans un immense bain
d'hémoglobine qui n'ont de cinéma
actuellement e-bike c'est bien les
spécialistes le disent le fantastique et
l'horreur sade et ça défoule
ça provoque le grand frisson qui calme
les gens c'est possible après tout même
si tout le monde n'est pas obligé
d'aimer ça en tout cas robert werner lui
s'est bien amusé ce festival
ça c'était le cinéma d'épouvanté de nos
papas mais pour ce nouveau public
ô combien raffiné à vide d'aurore
nouvelle c'est dépassé aujourd'hui le
film fantastique et le pin d'horreur
colle à la réalité il la déforment
seulement
haïti
les tombes 30 films sont projetés durant
ce festival du film fantastique à paris
trois films par soirée la plupart
d'entre eux n'ont jamais été vus en
france ils proviennent du monde entier
mais l'aînée comment l'horreur au cinéma
et bien à l'horreur est né avec le
cinéma expressionniste allemand c'était
un cinéma qui est issu des crises qui
ont bouleversé l'allemagne
ensuite ça a été les années 30 aux états
unis et dans une période aussi
d'insécurité c'était le crash de wall
street
et ça et on a pu remarquer une évolution
du cinéma d'horreur
en parallèle aux bouleversements
économiques aux socios l'angoissent née
du son de plusieurs sont superposées qui
deviennent terrible
mamour
je suis amateur littérature fantastique
donc je vais retrouver des sensations
que j'ai eues en lisant les vivres à
l'égout peut être ensemencé c'est
folklorique c'est ce qui fait le moins
peur aux gens mais bon bon ben alors
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous au nom
de toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité je
vous conseille nous mettre au lit avec
un roman d'amour
romain l'eau de rose pour oublier tout
ça dernier journal joseph poli vers 23h
merci de votre attention